présidente ma question s'adresse à
Monsieur le Ministre de l'économie et
porte sur la méthode de calcul du taux
d'usure je ne compte plus les messages
de nos concitoyens déçus de nos pouvoirs
accomplir le projet d'une vie qui est
l'accession à la propriété un dossier de
prêt sur 5 en moyenne a été refusé entre
mars et mai 2022 la situation a continué
par ailleurs de se dégrader avec un taux
de refus d'un dossier sur Torah voir 50%
des dossiers refusés pour les
primo-accédants effectivement en
additionnant le taux d'intérêt
d'assurance des emprunteurs très vite le
taux d'usure est atteint et la demande
des ménages est facilement rejetée les
premières victimes sont par ailleurs les
familles modestes disposant d'un faible
apport personnel avec un taux de crédit
trop proche de l'usure certes la
situation n'est pas nouvelle puisque les
taux d'usure ont été révisées en octobre
à 3,05% pour les crédits de 20 ans et
plus et à 3,03% pour les durées plus
courtes mais les établissements
bancaires ont très vite remonté leur
taux or en période de remontée sensible
des taux de prêt un pincement se produit
entre les taux bancaires pratiqués et le
taux d'usure calculé sur le trimestre
précédent trop en décalage de la réalité
des taux réels bref l'accès au crédit
immobilier se dégrade je ne conteste pas
la notion même de taux d'usure mais ça
mécanique se retourne aujourd'hui contre
ceux qu'elle doit protéger des
mécanismes simples et efficaces existent
afin de remédier à cette situation je
pense par exemple à l'actualisation
mensuelle du taux d'usure ou à la
révision de son mode de calcul ma
question est alors simple comment
comptez-vous intervenir sur le taux
d'usure pour permettre au ménage
d'accéder à la propriété je vous
remercie